EMPLOYEES TO CARRY HANDGUNS.
SCOTT HAS PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED TO
THAT IDEA.
LATER THIS MONTH, THE HOUSE
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND COMMERCE
COMMITTEE WILL BE LOOKING AT 20
DIFFERENT PIECES OF LEGISLATION
TO TRY TO FIGHT THE U.S.'S
GROWING OPIOID CRISIS.
IT COMES AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
STRUGGLES AGAINST THE USUAL
SUSPECTS AND THE UNUSUAL ONES
COME AS WELL.
CORRESPONDENT JONATHAN SERRIE
TELLS US TONIGHT ABOUT THAT.
>> POLICE.
>> FEDERAL AGENTS TAKING DOWN AN
ALLEGED DRUGS FOR SEX RING IN
ATLANTA, THE MAN OF THE TOP, A
FORMER MEDICAL EXAMINER.
>> HE'S A FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST.
WHY IS THIS PERSON ABLE TO WRITE
1500 PRESCRIPTIONS IN A TWO YEAR
PERIOD?
90% OF THEM ARE FOR PAIN
MEDICINE.
SPEAK OF A SPECIAL AGENT IN
CHARGE OF THE DRUG ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTRATION'S ATLANTA
FIELD DIVISION.
HE AND HIS AGENTS RECENTLY
ARRESTED MULTIPLE DEFENDANTS
TIED TO DR. JOSEPH BURTON, WHO
IS ACCUSED OF WRITING
UNNECESSARY OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS
IN EXCHANGE FOR SEXUAL FAVORS
SEXUAL FAVORS.
>> THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
CONFLICT TALKS ABOUT POLICING
THEMSELVES.
WE HOPE THAT HAPPENS.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT DOESN'T.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO COME IN AND
POLICE IT.
>> DEA ACTIONS AGAINST
PHYSICIANS MORE THAN QUINN
TUMBLED FROM 88 CASES IN 2011 TO
479 CASE IN 2016, ACCORDING
TO RESEARCH BY GEORGE MASON'S
UNIVERSITY DR. TONY YOUNG.
EACH STATE GIVES PRESCRIPTION
DRUG MONITORING DATABASE, TO
HELP THEM RED FLAG EXCESSIVE
ACTIVITY.
BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCESS TO
THESE AXES VARIES FROM STATE TO
STATE.
GEORGIA CURRENTLY REQUIRES A
SEARCH WARRANT OR SUBPOENA.
>> GEORGIA'S VERSION OF THE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MONITORING
DATABASE IS NOT AS ACCESSIBLE TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS OTHER STATES.
>> A BILL PENDING IN THE GEORGIA
LEGISLATURE WOULD FIX SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE STATES
DATABASE BUT DOES NOT ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF ACCESS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> ALTHOUGH GEORGE'S DATABASE
HELPED POLICE AND PROSECUTORS
BUILD THEIR CASE AGAINST
DR. BURTON, THEY SAY EARLIER AND
EASIER ACCESS MIGHT HAVE HELPED